welcome back it's the moment we've all
been waiting for it's the moment you've
been waiting for
our secret santa gift exchange i'm gonna
kick it off and open my gift first
here's my gift number one it's like you
know
christmas eve you're rushing under the
tree if you're a kid even if you're an
adult
and what did i get what did i get look
it's a bird
it's a bird like it's a plane
that's pretty cool all right so here's
my second gift
all right here's my second gift hey and
it's the plane
and now it's a plane
yeah if you're a fan of the show you get
the joke
you get the joke all right and my third
gift
i think this will this could fly high
it's great
a tequila gift that's a great guess yeah
i think
that was that's me but you have to do
something for me
you have to say it's a bird it's a plane
it's tequila
oh why not jesse anything to make you
happy to make your christmas day
it's a bird it's a plane
hey it's really tequila
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right i want one oh i thought there
was one last gift here
hey look i broke the bank it's something
from my
from my washington football team a hat
thank you guys okay dana awesome you're
up
new home thank you all right i have
three gifts
very cute wrapping paper and also can i
just say big thanks to the producers who
figured out how to get all of us
our gifts here remotely we appreciate it
oh we went over
and dane is always the little teacher's
pet
i got some sort of oh it's a it's four
plush toys for dogs
which are really i think for me but you
know any anything yeah it's very cute
i love that there's a little monkey in
there oh and it looks like a movie night
or something
okay number two since i know we got a
lot of people here number two
whoa let's see
i feel like i feel like jesse wants to
come clean up my
little compartment here huh
[Laughter]
yes i know his head's so
big it doesn't fit over your face there
are so many comments that
no one can say so we'll just say no one
can say it
yes no one can say look at that
there was another one it's evidence of
humility yes
there was another mask there was another
mask in there yeah
you think i'd forget jasper i thought
there was a jasper
oh dear i'm sorry i'm so
so flustered that mask was oh well
look at this
yes i did also thank you greg for my
cds so that i can learn about
real music that's the first time in my
life so what you've got in there is a
collection
of class racks anthrax that's among the
living
slayer rain and blood yeah power trick
jesse as soon as i download these to my
uh cassette tapes
i will hand them over to you
in there dana you have the new mr bungle
album the raging
wrath of the easter bunny as well as
power trips nightmare logic
these are the four best thrash metal cds
out right now so you should get you
should
go home now and listen to them i love it
christmas music thank you greg
thank you wait yeah yeah i love it i bet
you love it
yeah i i think there's gonna be a
dumpster fire out back of the house
tonight yeah all right greg you're up
all right
this is pretty heavy
ah oh yeah man that was pretty funny
what all right
i love i love that mass dana whoopsie i
don't know what we're gonna do
this is box one i think you're gonna
have to like do the
speed this up for the break because this
is like serious uh
you can't get in there make it like come
on girl fast walking
it's all like hmm
look at the muscles there's gotta be a
pony in there somewhere
perky jerky it's all a bunch of beef
jerky turkey
[Applause]
oh my god what is this strength it's the
armstrong
great i've got that mask all over me
wait wait oh
what the hell is this what is that it a
pull-up bar
a drone torture device it's a who who
got me this
i got porsches i'll tell you what it is
i will tell you it you put that under
your desk greg and you can pedal away
while you're at the office oh now this
is what i'm
premium summer sausage now you're
talking my language
oh it's this is kind of this is crazy
uh stuff and i got a little bomb
you got all right i got one more box hey
greg
wait wait greg you gotta you gotta react
to that bike
under the desk that's a i've never seen
anything like this are you gonna use it
for the peloton king i am i don't know i
mean yes of course i'll use it this is
exactly what i hoped for and dreamed of
some some more exercise in my life all
right
yeah i hope that this
is not as difficult to open
are you having a connection about all
this wrapping paper everywhere
i yeah
here we go what is this what is that
it's a pel is this a peloton jacket
it's a pet
[Applause]
after my workouts when i want to go to
the coffee shop this is what i'll wear
and i'll just sip coffee outside and
feel like i'm better than everyone else
in my little peloton jacket
you know what i didn't well you look you
know what
you know let's give credit to greg
yeah and he's gotten in pretty good
shape so you're gonna look smelt
out there while you're drinking that
coffee you got it okay with more of our
secret santa exchange with jesse and
emily
all right who goes first jessie let's
make emily last as usual
i'll go first
oh don't you love to just rip wow
silk eagles bathrobe
you're welcome oh man i thought i should
actually wear this
next show we do like williams did with
his snowflake jacket
i will be wearing this yeah emily thank
you very much and i will have something
under it i promise
you no not over a suit no
um gift number two it already fell out
of the wrapping whoever wrapped this
emily did a terrible job but thank you
i'm not surprised because i saw this
earlier today an eagles onesie oh
look at that how cute i had the same one
you're a new baby
greg yes so disgusting you know
um so jesse an eagles fan giving
exactly and i toyed with giving you
raiders diapers
because then you know there's the whole
like the team that you don't like you
put them on
or then but your baby would be repping
so i went with the safety
with the safety one and um well those
would have been cowboys diapers
in the nfc juan knows all right last one
from emily thank you these are great so
far
you're welcome i mean it's not the heavy
metal cd
actually used yes because you said
that you've gotten into skincare so
we thought that this would be you know
to go with your new regimen
so glad you brought that up again
on television thank you so much emily i
can't wait
to apply all of the masks and the creams
and the de-wrinklers
thank you so much i'm serious merry
christmas
that's a good one very good glowing
already jesse all right
emily is it you yes okay so this
is the first one
slippers oh my god how cute you guys
these are totally great we can't see oh
my god they say number one fan
hallmark channel these are amazing these
are totally perfect
i love the hallmark channel i literally
i literally watch
christmas movies on the armor channel
all the time emily this is what you just
said
you guys amazing and literally in the
same sense
i mean that's you just hit for the cycle
right there yes
emily i i thought i i think that's you i
can see you on the couch with the
hallmark christmas movies
it's pure heaven uh one you're amazing
you totally
nailed the gift with us thank you so
much thank you okay so my second one
this says number two
lindor on the outside
[Applause]
chocolates irresistibly oh my god
amazing
delicious you're the best gift recipient
i've ever seen
i know she'll could beat it because i
love gifts this is totally great one
thank you so much okay and then number
three
if you gave her calls and chalk
i'm grateful greg god and i like juan
and he's nice to me there you go
it's a santa
what is it it's um it's a toy
for duchess it is
oh it's an outfit oh my god
oh my god
oh so it's yes so it's totally like that
scene in labyrinth remember that one
little puppet that
or a muppet that um rides oh my god this
is amazing this is going to be
hysterical i'll make sure to take tons
of pictures
well done thank you so much you guys
merry christmas
that